ESPN NBA analyst and also a voice of the
NBA Finals on ESPN for many here's Jeff
Van Gundy back here in the program how
are you coach everything I'm doing fine
so how do you take in the news that that
Chris Paul will not be available on
Saturday night for Houston well
obviously it's a blow I mean he's a
great player but to think that they
can't win on the road without him would
be doing a disservice to the greatness
of James Harden and also to a defense
that has absolutely just put an elite
elite offensive team in shackles and so
I give them a good chance to close out
game the series in game six is that
right so why I guess I know you just I
think I offensively I would have never
thought I would have seen Golden State
look as flustered as stagnant as
stationary as they do this switching one
through five that both teams employ but
basically on every every cross of two
players they switch has really flattened
out Golden State much more than I ever
would have suspected and you know to
hold that team in the 90s two state
straight games an incredible feat by
Houston and likewise for an elite
offensive team like Houston to be held
down offensively three straight games
and win two of them I think just shows
you that there are such a balanced team
and and really when you think of Houston
they're not one game away from advancing
to the final they're one game away from
winning the championship they're healthy
okay let's let's let's dive into that a
little bit more because obviously you're
seeing their potential opponent up close
and personal every single night
including tonight
what makes you say that Jeff well I
think Boston is the better of the two
teams and I think they would have the
better the chances to to give both
Golden State or Houston whoever advances
you know the best run because I think
defensively they're the most equipped
you know this game has turned into such
an isolation series in the Western
Conference because of all the switching
it's become a one-on-one contest and I
think Boston has such great versatility
defensively now they've got their own
limitations offensively but defensively
they would make it competitive but it
would be I'd be hard-pressed to see if
Paul's healthy how they could beat
Houston or goal in the Dayton series
Jeff Van Gundy here on the Rich Eisen
show what what has happened to the Cavs
night-in night-out where they're so
up-and-down so inconsistent sometimes
look like they're asleep Jeff there's no
other way to put it just lack of energy
lack of cohesion and then obviously when
they get on their home court like
they'll be tonight it's a different
story what what are you seeing from this
team well I think you see that's for a
lot of players in our league the ability
to transfer their game from home to road
is inconsistent at best except for the
starved star players right and so to me
I know a lots been made out of the idea
that Cleveland is somehow underachieved
and these playoffs
I look at it totally different I look at
is like they've achieved a lot because I
don't I mean you take Kyrie Irving off
their team and you you look at their
lineup and you ask yourself you know
after James
where does Cleveland have the advantage
matchup life and the answer to me is
nowhere and I thought in and it's
happened you know Houston's gone to it
and and now Boston's gone to it they've
cut down the number of guys they played
cuz seven
and so they're keeping their best
players on the floor for all 240 minutes
they're not gifting you any minutes with
lesser players or less experienced
players who are not capable of playing
well in the moment and you've seen
Cleveland do the same they first cut out
clarkson's minutes and then they cut out
hoods minutes then they you know put
Clarkson back in for four and then
lastly we played a lot more dude it was
a blowout but you're seeing a lot of
that so I just don't think Cleveland's s
even nearly close to as good as they
have been and so I don't look at it like
they're underachieving
I just looked at it as everybody is
under estimating Boston and Boston's
talent because of the injuries they've
had and because they look at the number
you know the experience factor and
overweighting the experience factor
compared to how talented they are Jeff
Van Gundy head coach of the USA men's
basketball team as well here on the Rich
Eisen show so let me ask you this Jeff
with your coaching acumen and your and
your decades of experience there as well
as your own to are seeing Stephens Brad
Stevens work up close what are you
seeing that people are singing his
praises about well he's an outstanding
coach I mean the guy is like you saw it
at college and Butler you see it with
Boston they do a great job defensively
they run good actions they're unselfish
but the thing that I love about him but
let me say this rich - yep so Brad
Stevens is a great great basketball
coach right but somehow in this whole
talk like tie room have gotten a short
shift as far as his coaching I think
what he's had to manage and it may be
different it may be like totally
different but he doesn't have an easy
group by any stretch and they've won a
championship with them they've got to
another finals and they're in the
Eastern
in finals again and I don't think people
even approach giving him credit that he
deserves well no you know you know that
the reason for that is a lot of people
think all he's got to do is roll the
basketballs out there's 23 who's calling
the place and choosing the players that
he plays with yeah you know what
first of all if you're going eliminate
talking about the greatness of coaches
because they've had great players well
you're not going to talk then about Phil
Jackson you're not going to talk about
Pat Riley you're not going to talk about
Red Auerbach
red Holtzman I mean listen if you're
just going to eliminate and not give
credit to coaches who've won because
they've had great players well you can't
be a great coach without having your
name attached to a great player so
that's a little bit nonsensical to me
but to get back to Brad Steven the thing
I admire the most about Brad besides his
greatness as a coach is his humility as
he's getting all this praise is his
dignity as his integrity
I really admire him as a person well
going back and forth between Boston last
140 here Jeff
going back and forth between Boston and
Cleveland and being around the practices
of being around everybody the chatter
that maybe you have picked up is it safe
to stay that not only is obviously the
season on the line for the Cavs but
LeBron second tenure in Cleveland is on
the line tonight as well yeah I'm not so
sure I don't you know I don't think he
has a big circle that he confides in so
I think a lot of it if you hear it it's
just rumor and innuendo that's not based
on anything upon fact so I would look at
it like where can he go and make a max
salary where he has a better chance to
win and I don't have a place that I
would say that's possible and maybe one
opens up but I think one thing I do know
you know he says or and every athlete
says this right now like when asked
about their future I haven't given it
one bit of thought
and again if there was a lie-detector
test
attached that thing would be beeping
because it's human nature you're gonna
definitely think about what's in your
future and your you'll have the ability
as a professional to do both to be
locked in on the future or locked in on
the President and also have given some
thought to the to the future so I'm sure
he knows what he wants to do but I don't
think outside of a very few close
friends anyone really has a good idea of
what it is
especially when you have wife and kids
who might be saying you know what are
you thinking like where do you think
will be and I think you know I think he
has at least one child that's
approaching high school age and so you
know that's when it to me it becomes you
know trickier and trickier because it's
supposed to be a really good player and
you want to make it such that he has his
best chance of success as well and I
don't you know well we're just on the
subject to just go deeper into it let's
say remove the max contract out of it
Jeff I mean he's got money he's got his
his King he's he's got a whole second
act once he's done with football already
set up up and running with him and
maverick Carter where do you think if he
just removes max contract from is the
best spot for him to win well to win
yeah that's what that that's pretty much
all he needs left well that would take
him that would take you know man
well I don't think anybody wouldn't take
him if you take the contract out of it I
mean if they were bran James and it's
just are you better with his test with
his game and talent and all that comes
with James yeah I mean he could go to
all 30 teams so I think his best chances
would be to win would be to go to Golden
State would be to go to Boston would be
to go to Houston Chile would be another
one so yeah I mean the the teams that
are you know that have younger bases
that you could add is greatness to why
not let's have James go to go
State and give no-one a chance for get a
timeshare there in the Oakland area Jeff
you know and you'll be there every
single June do you last one for you then
do you think you will be in in Boston on
Memorial Day do you think that's gonna
happen
um I waking up they're after us yeah
yeah I think they're gonna win tonight
here I thought they'd win in five
Cleveland to me has done a good job of
getting adhere to the six game the way
they played at home I wouldn't be
surprised at all Cleveland guys to a
seventh game and if they do get it to a
seventh game even though they've been
you know hammered pretty good in all
three games on the road to think that
LeBron James and that team couldn't
muster up one great road game would be
silly so I think Boston their approach
just like Houston's approach better be
let's end it now
love the chat Jeff as always hopefully
we'll chat during the during the finals
will definitely be give me a call okay
take care thanks again you got that Jeff
Van Gundy the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience